this video is sponsored by the book
summary service
blinkist the first 100 people to use the
link in the description
will receive one week of free unlimited
access plus 25
off a full membership what does it mean
to live well
and be virtuous in a world of suffering
chaos
and deterioration what does it mean to
go on living in a consciousness
that is inevitably bound to the struggle
of it only becoming more confused and
tormented as it becomes more capable and
aware
generally speaking most religious and
philosophical concepts are spurred out
of these sorts of challenges and
questions
they represent humanity's attempt to
overcome or deal with the deficiencies
and difficulties bestowed into each pair
of unrequested human hands
one perhaps especially unique example of
such an attempt
is the philosophy and religion of
buddhism
[Music]
somewhere between 6th and 4th century bc
in what is now southern nepal
a boy named siddhartha gautama was born
he was born to an aristocratic family
his father shorodhana being the king of
a growing state in the indian
subcontinent
when siddhartha was born a holy
messenger prophesied that he would
become one of two things
either a great king or a great religious
leader
when receiving this prophecy being the
conservative king that his father was
he determined that he would ensure that
siddhartha would become the former he
would ensure this by completely
sheltering siddhartha confining him
within a massive palace he had
configured away and walled off from the
rest of the world
rigidly filtering what was allowed in by
a standard of perfect health
beauty and luxury constantly cleansing
the palace of any signs of imperfection
discomfort misery ugliness illness and
death
preventing siddhartha from ever knowing
they existed
all of this in shortadana's mind was to
create a world that would be easy for
siddhartha to fall in love with
and desire kingship of removing any need
to consider
question or become interested in
religious and spiritual domains
throughout his childhood and into early
adulthood however siddhartha would
for this very reason become increasingly
curious and begin probing into life
at 29 years old his existential
curiosity finally boiled over the walls
of the palace
and into the unknown and prohibited
kingdom of beyond
at this point siddhartha would make the
decision to take his first journey out
of the palace
and into the world
in anticipation of this in an effort to
maintain the masquerade of a perfect
redeemable world
his father ordered the streets to be
removed of all signs of pain
suffering sickness old age and death
despite this however while on his
journey siddhartha would still happen by
an extremely sick man
his body obviously blemished and written
on by the conditions of his ailment
when siddhartha saw this he asked the
chariot driver whom he was being
escorted by
what was wrong with the man the chariot
driver informed siddhartha that the man
was sick
and explained to him what this meant
after returning to the palace for a
little while on a second journey out
at some point siddhartha would next be
exposed to an elderly man
who looked extremely feeble frail and
wrinkled
again when he saw this having never seen
an elderly person of such
age he asked the driver what was wrong
the driver informed him of the
phenomenon of aging
and how like that man all human bodies
grow old with time
decaying growing unattractive and
becoming weak
again after returning to the palace for
a little while on a third journey out
this time siddhartha would encounter a
funeral procession occurring through the
streets
exposing him to for the first time a
dead body
again siddhartha asked what was wrong
and was informed by the driver
about death and the impending finite
limit of all living things
now completely and utterly devastated by
his collection of newfound insights
into the fragility of the physical body
the temporal horizon of age
and the finite terminating nature of
existence of which all living things
including himself would inevitably face
he felt the final straw break
destroying his comfortable sheltered
youthful image of the world
and replacing it with its true
horrifying one
realizing this truth of the world now
siddhartha could no longer return and
stay in the palace
rather he found himself compelled by a
new quest to overcome
and deal with this image of life
on a fourth journey siddhartha now
seeking answers
noticed a meditating holy man in the
city who seemed to be at complete peace
amidst the horrors that surrounded him
curious about the man's apparent ability
to attain such a state
after inquiring into him siddhartha
would become inspired and spend the
following many months on a sort of
spiritual quest
seeking holy practices ideas and answers
however being a very pragmatic and
inquisitive man by this point
refusing to mindlessly agree with the
conventions orthodoxies
and blind faiths required for many of
the religious ideas and practices of the
time
siddhartha found himself at the very
brink of available ideologies and
methods
still completely unsatisfied at some
point
along with a group of several other men
siddhartha would engage in the extreme
radical spiritual practice known as
asceticism
which involves a complete renunciation
of earthly indulgences and pleasures
in an attempt to deprive the body and
free the self
after many months of starving himself
into an unrecognizably weak
malnourished skin draped collection of
bones siddhartha still had found nothing
in the form of answers or resolutions to
life
he could not think straight and the
extreme physical deprivation
only created more futile suffering and
so
he began to eat food again returning
back somewhere into the middle of the
two extremes
now ostracized by the ascetic men for
what they felt was giving up
siddhartha would continue on his own
meditating alone in the forest away from
the rest of the entire world
he would continue to both eat and
meditate not depriving his body
nor pursuing much beyond what his body
needed for basic comfort
throughout this period siddhartha would
experience a collection of introspective
realizations
and it was here that siddhartha would
begin to formulate his fundamental
philosophical tenets
and it was here that sadartha's story
would become the story
of the buddha or the enlightened one
in this moment buddhism would begin its
journey in human history
challenging and changing the course of
religious social
and philosophical orthodoxy forever
in truth it isn't clear how much of the
buddha's story is real or fable
if not entirely fable most of what is
known about the buddha and his teachings
are based on oral accounts that were
written down centuries after his death
leaving plenty of room for various
interpretations and supplementary
details to be added
and twisted furthermore there are
numerous versions of a story that are
accepted as accurate
each with at least slightly different
details tones
spiritual references and overarching
implications
however regardless of literal accuracy
and variation
the general story of the buddha arguably
always remains the same at its core
it is a story of us all the story of
growing up
becoming curious and tempted seeking to
move out and beyond the borders of the
sheltered reality
maintained by our parents society and
our underdeveloped psyche
beginning to discover life's
contaminated horrors for the first time
and the extreme lengths we often go to
in order to try to understand
overcome and escape them
in terms of buddha's specific
philosophical ideas his core principles
are contained in what he termed
the four noble truths the first noble
truth being that life is fundamentally
suffering
no matter who or what all living things
are bound and connected by this
intrinsic
existential quality of suffering in its
broadest sense
the second noble truth proposes that
this suffering is a consequence of our
desires
and attachments the third truth in a
revolutionary way of thinking for its
time
goes on to argue that since suffering is
a product of attachment and desire
one can personally overcome and end
suffering by eliminating or
recalibrating their desires and
attachments
the fourth and final noble truth
contains the steps buddha believed were
necessary to do so
this collection of steps would be named
the noble eightfold path
also often referred to as the middle way
these eight steps include right view
right intention right speech right
action right livelihood right effort
right mindfulness and right
concentration these concepts are not so
much steps to be achieved or discovered
in a linear order
but rather a wheel of actively
circulating behaviors and wisdoms
that one must constantly be turning in
broad summary it essentially calls for
the practice of wisdom
humanistic morality through universal
compassion
moderation self-knowledge and reaching
enlightenment or nirvana
through non-attachment and the
elimination of desire
essential to the success of buddhist
teachings is this final idea of
non-attachment
and no desire admittedly this concept
can sound rather convoluted
or at the very least counter-intuitive
at first but it starts by recognizing
the true nature of the self
which is in at least one interpretation
of the buddhist teachings
non-self or emptiness buddha argued that
fundamentally
our external world is in perpetual
unattainable flux and consequently
so too are we we are but collections of
constantly changing qualitative
interactions between the world
and our thoughts and thus the idea of a
fixed
independent identifiable self is a
delusion
this is essential to understand because
it suggests that the self that we are
trying to satisfy
escape or eternalize never even really
exists in the first place
rather the capital i that we describe is
merely a state of emptiness
constantly being filled and emptied by
the succession of each moment
this concept can perhaps be experienced
distinctly when one considers how there
is no real central point of sensation
and experience when one experiences
something like smell
mental vision taste memory or emotion
of course they can be pointed to the
mind but where in the mind
after the nose who or what is smelling
or let's say if you imagined a purple
cat right now
and visualized it in your head where is
the purple cat
how is the purple cat where are you
seeing it from
there is just a blank emptiness filled
up by the interacting thoughts and
sensations of the moment
all becoming one constantly changing
hybrid of self
and material world buddha's teachings
are about reorienting our view of
ourself
so that we see this that there is none
so we can then
reorient our view of the world according
to the buddha
we suffer not as a result of not having
enough things like money
status success or ideal external
circumstances
but because the desire for such things
is attached to the impossible delusion
of a permanent self capable of being
satisfied by desire
and the only way out of this is ending
or at least attempting to reduce
one's dependence on such desires and
attachments
living with some form of restrained
moderation and conquering the prodding
delusion of self
though one may conquer a thousand times
a thousand men in battle
yet he indeed is the noblest victor who
conquers himself
self-conquest is far better than the
conquest of others
not even a god an angel mara or brahma
can turn into defeat
the victory of a person who is
self-subdued and ever restrained in
conduct
said the buddha of course buddhism is
not without its shortcomings and
outdated artifacts
for secular types its religious
association can likely pose its fair
share of problems
and outside of this just in terms of its
general core principle
can one truly desire no desire does this
work as a final desire
ceasing the very thing required to enact
it or does it create a mirage effect
that holds us in further submission to
it moreover to what extent do we really
have any control over our desires
the information we encounter and how it
all works together to affect us
and as the world and humanity continues
to develop further and further
and temptations and indulgences and
distractions
seep into every corner of modern
societal life we are likely left with at
the very least
an extremely difficult uphill climb into
even the secular form of his teachings
however regardless of this and any other
difficulties or pitfalls
buddhism still remains a highly unique
and compelling system of thinking
over millennia it has seen many
different iterations interpretations
updates and effects not only in the east
but also in the west
even influencing many significant
western philosophers by the likes of
arthur schopenhauer
friedrich nietzsche ralph waldo emerson
emil charon
alan watts likely david hume and many
others
currently it is the world's fourth
largest religion with over half a
billion followers worldwide
primarily divided into two main
overarching categories
theravada and mahayana at its core
buddhism still remains one of the most
unique and dynamic schools of religious
thought
grounding its ideas in empirical
experience and practical methodologies
making its wisdom accessible without
necessarily depending on any gods
or faith in the unknowable and
untouchable bringing the spiritual down
into the hands of the pragmatic everyday
person
and perhaps most significantly it
confronts the suffering and darkness of
life directly
and does not keep us in the palace of
ignorance it does not try to lie to us
it does not shelter or cuddle it makes
its best efforts to find the minimums
and maximums of life
and lead us down a path towards some
semblance of hope and living well
in spite of what's really out there
this video was sponsored by blinkist
with the new year beginning that
additional motivation to start or
improve habits
is possibly doing its little annual
dance in the back of your head
of course the new year is really no more
than just one day turning into another
with a different arbitrary number
attached to it but whether you're
looking to leverage that nonetheless
worthwhile force of motivation
achieve some new or old goals or simply
improve the degree of your understanding
of the world and self in general
blinkist makes the habit of reading and
learning
much easier to start and sustain
blinkist is a book summary app that
condenses over 3 000 non-fiction books
into around 15-minute summaries
providing the main ideas and key
takeaways
in a convenient amount of time all
summaries can either be read or listened
to like a podcast
and can be accessed even while offline
if you're interested in learning more
about topics related to buddhism
blinkist has some great titles including
no self no problem
by chris niebauer which explores the
overlap between ancient buddhist ideas
and modern neuroscience as well as
several other similarly related titles
including why buddhism is true by robert
wright
waking up by sam harris and several
others
blinkist now also has complete audio
books that you can purchase directly
within the app
as well as consolidated summaries of
various popular podcasts from around the
world
perhaps most usefully blinkist can help
you stay on a smoother more
intentional track of learning and
reading by making it easier for you to
determine if you are interested in new
books
authors or topics prior to having to
read full versions first
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access
as well as 25 percent off a full
membership the free 7-day trial can be
canceled at any time within the trial
period
again if you're interested please visit
blinkist.com
pursuit of wonder or click the link in
the description below
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
uh